how does one make it in Hollywood Wow
that's the million dollar question I
think if I could simply answer that I'd
be able to be a millionaire just by
giving that advice you know it's it's
extremely competitive it's extremely
difficult industry to break into I
sometimes compare it to professional
sports like wanting to be in the NFL or
the NBA you know it's one of those
things that people grow up dreaming
about wanting to be a part of but in
fact very few people end up actually
making a living being in that profession
I actually don't think there's a ton of
luck in in the writing game because
writing is one of those things where you
have a scripts you know it's a hundred
and twenty pages or thirty pages for a
TV show or 60 pages for a TV show and
it's either good or it's not good and it
doesn't really matter whose name is on
that cover page once someone starts
reading that script they're gonna know
if they're engaged by this writing or if
they're not engaged by the writing you
really need to get the person you're
pitching to see the story to get them to
be able to see the movie
as clearly as possible and sometimes
that means being extremely detailed and
sometimes it's a matter of having
specific details that take them into the
world of it and then having sort of more
of a general discussion than having the
entire thing you know beat it out a
moment for a moment so it varies from
project to project but definitely the
ultimate goal is to do whatever you can
to get the person as immersed in the
story as possible the first pitch I ever
sold was the pitch for recount and that
was a very long pitch it was 35 minutes
long but I really wanted them to
understand all the multi-dimensional
facets to the story of the Florida
recount so I opened the pitch with a
fake a replica of the butterfly ballot
and I said we opened the movie on this
and I set the butterfly ballot down and
then I took them through the movie not
as a history lesson but as the story of
how I saw the movie lay out you know I
said Ron Klain and James Baker in the
Battle of these two men and then I
brought in Katherine Harris and made it
is is cinematic a-tellin as possible and
then when I was done at the end of the
page
I showed them a two-minute video clips
of the actual Florida recount to give
them you know images of what it was
really like down there to just immerse
them in the story as much as possible
and I knew because I was pitching HBO
who you know only hires you know very
experienced writers and I had never sold
anything that this was gonna have to be
one hell of a presentation if I was
gonna get them to hire me to do this
movie